i'm gonna come to like you you guys
first what do you want to hear a rap
about
the queen the queen do you want to pick
a specific aspect of the queen make it
more like more challenging
looks the queen's looks oh yeah baby
that 94 year old hottie
you guys over here we got the queen's
looks what's it gonna be
labor day amazing what a great
suggestion to give the british guy a
holiday that he's not even sure what
it's about
everyone gets pregnant and gives birth i
don't know
labor day the queen's looks uh front row
what hacking amazing as in like yeah
cool
um hey look i've only seen the matrix
that's what i think hacking is
cool that looks like someone just going
down on someone very badly
deleted scene from the matrix so hacking
labor day
the queen's looks um what
football wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait so football is said
all the time but then you specified that
what time
scc football sec
no what is that
the south eastern conference football
i'm excited for that bit because i
wow apparently oh you're going to hate
when i try and rap about it i know
nothing
and let's get one final one from you
guys over here
oh [ __ ] hell if you didn't hear what
he said
he said epstein because you piece of
[ __ ]
right the rule is i can't turn down
suggestions so
okay so we have sec football
epstein i'm presuming jeffrey right
yeah cool not okay
jeffrey epstein the queen's looks labor
day
and hacking this then lovely people at
the comedy seller a little treat for you
all a freestyle rap that is a wrap made
up on the spot based entirely on those
suggestions none of it has been
performed before
none of it is written it will never be
formed again and do not worry yourselves
it won't be anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly bad
as you are expecting a 29 year old
privately educated middle class british
white boy to be
yeah that's what i like let's drop that
beat let's drop that beat
let's do it i'm so excited
i mean i'm glad you're so skeptical
about this aren't you just looking over
there
down a bit got you in the front row
looking right at me
saying how's this white bro rapping bout
sec gonna make the words rhyme gonna
make it make sense yeah
talk about football south east
conference better than the north west
better than the west east when i see the
football players pay a visual feast for
the
eyes they've got meaty thighs i wanna
get their balls oval shaped my surprise
i kick a field goal how many points is
it i don't know nothing about just don't
quit
i don't even know why they switch teams
i'm hung up
on [ __ ] like jeffrey epstein i'm there
in a cell
on suicide watch conspiracy theories
they be like they scotched
all the ideals assassins lining up
trying to get him when he's in their
right locked up line
not jeffrey me with a rope again too
many underage hymens were broken
you've gotta punish die for your primes
put it around your neck like
several times yes pixie wank like he was
choking on limes
sorry let me move on no choking on lines
got
no knowledge here to say i wear white
white
because labor day that's the only thing
i know about it got no other facts
looking on my calendar i'm like i must
relax i've gotta look it up
on wikipedia after is it saturday or
sunday
that's a disaster monday probably i'd
give a wide birth
i should have saved the pun about women
giving birth it would have been better
if i put it right there i'm attacking
anybody in an office we care
i see a guy wearing a hoodie and glasses
there
got a macbook pro he's not aware that
i'm spying on him yeah
his skills lacking no surveillance when
i watch him happen
oh i'm amazing yes i'm on amazon i'm
going to get all the credit cards i'll
hammer some
here is a worm a trojan virus i know
nothing about computers just silence are
you i have to bro with the binary
probably maybe but in china they see
all the secrets they're hacking
nationally lasting yeah
actually what was the last one we needed
to do
it's in my dream it's wet when i wake
cause i dream of the queen
i see her oh yeah i wanna be in her
i don't mind that she's a reefer she's
got little corgis got little dogs
i wanna introduce her to my big log
that's disgusting
why would i say that it's treasonous
yeah that is a fact
i would find prince philip he's a 95
year old dude
i'm gonna get a cliff and push him off
move out of the way
there's a new king in town and then like
the hacking on the queen i'd go
down
[Applause]